les poils rasés repoussent plus drues
raser les poils ça les frais repousser
plus vite plus épais plus fort plus
nombreux plus cruels plus mais en fait
la seule chose qui change entre
l'épilation et le rasage c'est que dans
le premier cas on arrache le bulbe du
poil donc il doit recommencer à pousser
de 0
du coup un il met plus de temps à
réapparaître à la surface de la peau
donc il pousse pas moins vite il part
juste de plus loin de c'est un poil neuf
avec sa forme de poil qu'on connaît bien
alors que quand on le rase le poil il
est coupé net parfois même un peu en
biseau du coup le bout est pointu et
comme en plus il est très court donc pas
très souple ça pique
c'est rêche mais il est pas plus dru ah
oui et si les adolescents ont la barbe
et les poils des jambes qui poussent de
plus en plus à partir du moment où il
commence à les raser c'est juste parce
que c'est le concept de la puberté en
fait c'est les poils poussent de plus en
plus rasage ou par hasard